[音楽]
皆さんは
多様性という言葉を
聞いたことがあると思いますが
木の葉妖精という言葉
皆さんは
必要だと
思いますか
私は
必要ないと思います
多様性が当たり前になれば
自然と
多様性という言葉は必要なくなると思い
ます
では
多様性の社会に近づくために
何が大切か
私の考えを
話したいと思います
皆さんはブラインドサッカーという
スポーツを
ご存知ですか
私は
2004年から
プライ作監を行っています
ブラインドサッカーは
近くに
障がいがある方でも
サッカーを
楽しめるように
ルーいうを工夫して使えたスポーツです
なので当たり前ですが私にも
視覚に障害がいます
パッと見
見えているか
見えていないか
わからないかもしれませんが
普段
外を歩くときはう
これを持って歩いています
皆さんも
これを持って1
mature
駅で見たことがあると思います
これは薄情といって
これで
ランさや障害物
階段など
確認して歩いています
私は
生まれつき
資格に
障害があったわけではなくて
高校3年生の頃
遺伝性の病気で
徐々に視力が低下していき
今は
光を感じる程度しか
見えていません
ぐらいのサッカーは
パラリンピックの
正式競技で
あーりんピックでは
5人制サッカーと
呼ばれています
なので
選手が5人です
4人の選手が
この
アイマスクを付けて
見え方を統一します
ゴールキーパわー
目が見える人
ゴールを守るだけではなく
ディフェンスにしようだします
えんちーる監督は真ん中の指示
相手の号の後ろに
コーチが立ってるんですけども
そのコーチを
ガイドを読んでいて
ガイドはおへそしだします
見えない選手4人と
見えている
ゴールキーパー
監督
ガイド
この7人で
お互い声を掛け合って
ゴールを守ったり
ゴールを決めたりしています
私は
ブラインドサッカーを
約チューナー年間
行ってきて
コミュニケーション中要請を学びました
なぜ
くらいのサッカーでえっ
コミュニケーション重要性が
わかるかというと
見えない人に配して
スタイル
その難しさを
感じたからです
例えば
今私は手を挙げています
この手は
右でしょうか
左でしょうか
簡単ですが右ですよねー
では
みなさんから見たら
これは
右ですか
左ですか
左になりますよね
今私と皆さんは
画面を通して
向き合ってると思います
なので
私からみて右だとしても
皆さんにとっては
左になります
これを
ぐらいの作家イを支えて
私がガイドデー
皆さんが聖書とします
私は皆さんに
右に
鳥節てきてほしいといい
思っています
なので
右3
右にドライブしてかいっ
入ったとします
そうすると皆さんは私からみて左に
鳥見すると思います
私か見て右だとしても
皆さんにとっては左なので
右ではなく
左ハリー
左の霊夢すごい
といった方が伝わりますよね
これは
相手の質は
相手の目線に立たないと
伝わらないということです
次に
私が選手で
皆さんが
がいる落とします
このブライブサッカーのオールは
このように言っ
誰か釈迦堂
音が鳴るようになっています
中に名前の魂が入っていて
それがぶつかり合って
音が鳴るようになっています
でも
このようにボールが
止まってしまうと
音が鳴りません
この時に
みなさんなら
東声をかけますか
いろいろな声の吹き方があると思います
声のかけ方のコツとして
わかりやすく簡単にです
例えば
ボールは
私の
すぐ近くにあるので
そこそこ
県そこ
と
いたします
でもそこそこ
と言われても
そこってどこですかねぇ
見えない人に対して
アレコレソレや
あっちこっちそっち
と言われても
わからないですよね
もっと具体的に言わないと
伝わりません
が次に
方向
を委託するとします
私から見て
右に
ボールがあるので
右3件と実にいい
トップ
いたとします
私は右右と言われたので
このように
e 2 e
動きます
そうすると
ボールを蹴ってしまって
オーラどっかに行ってしまいます
右と言っても
いろんな
右があると思いませんか
今のように
右に動く合えば
右を抜く
もあると思いますし
右にボールがあるよ
もあると思います
このように
何を通して欲しいか
まで言わないと
つつありません
これは言葉に対して
人それぞれ
捉え方が
違うということです
私は
ブラインドサッカーん
体験を通して
具合のサッカーについてア
視覚障害の2回だけではなく
コミュニケーション中要請も伝わるんじゃ
ないかと思い
企業研修や
学校の授業で
ラン作の体験を
を行っています
ある
学校の
体験事業デー
こんなことがありました
見えている生徒が
i マースクをつけている生徒に向かって
声を掛けながら
目的地まで歩くという
ワークです
例えば
見えている生徒が
これゴール
半丸きたよ
ゴールまであと3名とだよ
はい凍りついたよ
といった
声かけを行います
でも
その生徒は
アイマスクを付けている制度に願って
おい何やってんだよ
早く所様
と言っていました
アイマスクつけている生徒は
見えない中で歩くのが強く
うまく
目的地まで
歩けなかったんですね
それに対して
おい何やってんだよ
早くしろよー
と言われても
できるものも
部屋があってしまいます
なぜこんな
ネガティブな声掛けを
してしまうのでしょうか
これは
見える見えない関係なく
できない人に対して
下に
見てるんだと思います
もっといいよいいよ
大丈夫だよ
あってるよ
といった
ポジティブな声掛けが
出来なのかなぁと
思ってしまいます
このように
超で関係が
何気ない会話の中で出ていませんか
会社であれば
上司トップか
学校だと
先生と生徒
スポーツだと
監督と選手
他には
家族や
友達てほしい
そして
障害がない人と
障がいがある人
誰かに
何かを教えときに
相手が
甘く入って来なかったとします
相手の理解能力にも問題があるかもしれ
ませんが
もしかしたら
教えている川にも
問題が
あるのかもしれません
皆さんが
なにげなく使っている言葉
ちゃんと
相手に
伝わっていますか
曖昧に伝わっていたり
違う意味で変わっていたり
もしかしたら相手を
気付こともあるかもしれません
特に今は
パソコンやスマートフォンが
普及していく中でねー
メールや
sns など
声でのコミュニケーションではなく
もしでの
コミュニケーションが増えてきてると思い
ます
文字で伝える方が
なおさら
難しいと思います
コミュニケーションは相手の立場になって
いっ
声をかける
言葉は人それぞれ
生え方が違う
当たり前ですが当たり前のことを当たり前
にやる
簡単なようで
実は難しいのかもしれません
私は
視覚障害の二階屋
多様性の社会の二回だけではなく
もっと
身近にいる人のの理解を深めていく必要が
あるのではないかと思っています
家族や友達
会社の仲間など
相手を理解するために
コミュニケーションが大切なのです
近くにいる人の異界ができなければ
多様性を社会には
近づけないのならないかと思っています
皆さんは
多様性の社会に近づくために
何が
必要だと思いますか
皆さんぼ
目を閉じてみてください
見えないから
見え着世界を
感じてください